- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV
program is presented
by University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow
us Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest programs.
(uptempo piano music)
We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal,
naked,
large-brained,
long the master of fire,
tools, and language
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future
from our shared understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here.
An exploration made
possible by the generosity
of humans like you.
(pensive piano music)
- I'm sure all of you came
away from the symposium
realizing that evolution, as Randy Ness
has repeatedly pointed
out, is the basic science
that's absolutely critical to medicine.
So you're probably wondering why UCSD,
maybe one of the only few
schools in the United States
where evolution is even taught
as part of the curriculum.
And it's not for any
religious, social, political,
or historical reason,
it's really an artifact
of the way medicine involved.
Medicine was an art that
had a shotgun marriage
with science in the 1920s and 1930s
in what is called western medicine.
At that time, evolution
wasn't an established science,
really because we didn't know
about DNA, genetics was not
yet known, and lots of
other things are not known,
so the new synthesis really happened only
in the 1950s and 1960s, by
which time it was too late,
the curriculum had been jammed
full of everything else.
And so while Randy and others led the way
in looking into this matter,
i think there's going to be
a lot more effort we have to take,
which is more of an effort we have to take
with our curriculum committees rather than
a scientific issue to ind truce evolution
and evolution biology more
into the medical curriculum,
so next time you go see
your doctor, ask him
do you understand evolution
while you're taking care of me?
Okay, so with that, I'll go to
the question answer session.
(pensive piano music)
- We're gonna start with
questions for Katie Hinde.
First question is, come on out, Katie.
If milk content varies based
on the infant's gender,
what's the signalling mechanism
that tells the mother's body
what this is, is it prenatal, and if
in male and female twins, who wins?
- Okay, that's a great question.
From dairy cows, because of the management
of the dairy industry, calves
are removed from the mom
at birth and they're fed a milk replacer
and the milk that the heifer is producing
is then used to feed us and so from that
we can evaluate if there's
differences in milk production
and if there are, that means
that they reflect something
about the prenatal environment, and indeed
in the dairy cows we've seen
that there is a signature
of the infant sex from
pregnancy and we hypothesized
that this has to do with
hormonal transfer from the fetus
into maternal circulation
that then influences
the functional development
of the mammary gland during pregnancy.
Experimental manipulation in bank voles,
in which they created all
male and all female litters
after they were born has also shown
that milk synthesis is
up-regulated when mothers
are rearing all daughter litters.
So there seems to be both
prenatal and postnatal
mechanisms that are influencing
how the mammary gland
knows that it's synthesizing
milk for sons and daughters.
The twin question is a
really, really good one
and whoever asked that
question find me afterwards
and I will tell you, 'cause
there's work that I've reviewed
that's now in press that
gives us some insights into
how milk produced for
son and daughter twins
may be different than what
would happen if there were
son son twins and daughter daughter twins,
but I can't say from the podium.
Thank you.
(applause)
- Next is a question for Mike Gurven
Mike, come on out.
Do helmets reduce the
incidents of atherosclerosis
to aid in their own survival
because the host lives longer
so they can?
- Thanks for the question.
There's nothing that worms
can't do, apparently.
No, it's a good question.
I think there's a variety of ways, yeah
helmets aren't trying to make
changes in our human bodies
just for our own benefit but, you know,
they're trying to ensure
their own growth and survival.
Now, intestinal helmets don't
reproduce inside the body
but of course, you know they
lead to the shedding of eggs
which will permit to spread
and so there's a variety
of different ways that helmets
actually exert their effects.
They're taking lipids,
consuming lipids and glucose
from our bodies, they're
altering the way that lipids
are metabolized and so
people with helmets tend
to actually have lower cholesterol levels.
We've seen that in the Chimane,
and it now exists in other populations
and also, they modulate immune function
in a variety of ways, as I
mentioned, that seem to be
regulatory and
anti-inflammatory and certainly,
the solution well, you know,
maybe we all need worms
is a hard one to address,
aside from the ick factor.
Your own body often can shed these worms.
Somehow evolution has
decided that our body
should tolerate them as Ruslan said,
rather than get rid of
them, and so the dynamic
we're actually still
trying to work this out
how helmets have co-evolved
with our immune system
in ways that our body almost
expects them to exist.
Thank you.
- One for Barbara Natterson.
If chimpanzees are so
closely related to humans,
why do we use species like
mice that are so distant
as models for human disease?
- Well, there are a number of ways
I could approach that question,
starting with the ethical
or starting with the scientific.
I guess my response quickly would be that
we have been overall very
disappointed with the mouse model
in many ways, you know it's
often said that we've cured
cancer thousands of times
in mice, but the problem is
it doesn't translate so well to humans.
I guess my comment would
be that there are ways
that we can begin to
advance science by looking
at the natural occurrence of
disease in non-human animals
because there are limitations
to experimental models.
Don't get me wrong, experimental
models are very valuable
and yet there's certain
diseases, for example bone cancer
osteosarcoma which happens
very commonly in large dogs
like Great Danes and
Labradors and Mastiffs
and the biology, the natural
history of this kind of cancer
in those dogs is nearly identical
to the biology in humans
who develop this problem,
typically adolescents.
And so this is an area that
we've really not looked at
and is hiding in plain
sight, an opportunity
to begin to understand and
ask important scientific
questions by looking at
the animals all around us,
not only our pets but also
wild animals, farm animals,
who are one their own developing
many of the same diereses
that we have.
- [Randolph] Thank you.
(applause)
- As you can tell, we're doing
questions from the speakers
before the break first, and
the last is Ruslan Medzhitov.
Do you know, or would
you predict the effect
of ketogenic metabolism on the outcome
during a viral infection?
And start by explaining what
ketogenic metabolism is.
- So presumably, what was
meant as ketogenic diet,
a diet that is rich in fats
and low in carbohydrates,
similar to Atkins Diet for example.
The answer is that it
depends on the duration
of the ketogenic diet
and how extreme it is,
if it's really only just fats
and no carbohydrates at all,
and it depends on what
is the limiting factor
during an infection, so we
shouldn't be just generalizing
it into any viral infection,
even for a given viral
infection, the limiting factor
could be viral-induced damage
or it could be viral-induced inflammation,
and ketogenic diet or ketons rather,
have various anti-inflammatory effects.
And that can help under
conditions when inflammation
is the limiting factor,
but generally being
on a ketogenic diet for long enough time
and if it's a very
aggressive ketogenic diet,
no carbohydrates at all, it
has also various side effects
such as ketoacedosis, which
leads to a drop in the pH
of the blood and that in
itself can have various effects
that can be deleterious on
the outcome of the infection
so there's a long way to say
that there is no simple recipe
or when our study was
published, somebody asked me
a question, how many candies
should I eat to prevent flu?
There is no answer like that and I think
only one general implication
I would say is that
it appears that our
bodies may have preference
for what we want to eat and
what we want to avoid eating
depending on our condition.
We all experience that in
difference and it's most obvious
in the case of an early pregnancy
when the food preferences
change dramatically, but that
also seems to be the case
with infections, so we have our
preferences for chicken soup
versus honey and tea
versus other types of food
and we think that these
are some ancient mechanisms
telling us which type of
metabolism would be protective.
But anything extreme, like ketogenic diet
or any one of those
diets, it's all of course,
much of it is nonsense
and we should just follow
more natural desires, thank you.
(applause)
- Okay, so we'll go to questions
from the second session,
a question for David Haig.
It's a bit complex, but I think
there's some interesting stuff in here.
For offsprings with defects
passed on maternally,
daughters may not suffer,
but will pass on genes
to their sons who exhibit defects.
Will defects in sons be
less in the first born
and more in the subsequent sons?
- There are a lot of
difficult questions there.
First of all, the genetic
defects we're looking at,
you know, those are the
mutations that Randy talked about
that just happen that
are bad and maladaptive,
but they provide information
about what the genes
that aren't working do
during normal development,
so I wouldn't want to
suggest that any of these
defect conditions are
adaptive in any sense.
Since I have the podium,
I want to put something out
there fascinating for you.
We now know that during
pregnancy, that once a woman
has been pregnant, cells
from each of her offspring
colonize her body and persist in her body
for the rest of her life.
And we also know that
there are populations
of maternal cells that
colonize in offspring bodies
and remain in those bodies,
often for the rest of the life.
During pregnancy, a mother's
mother's cells increase
in frequency in her blood,
and so there's a possibility
that maternal grandmother
cells can colonize a fetus.
And since cells from previous pregnancies
are in the mother's body,
there's a possibility
that cells of older siblings
can move across the placenta
and move into younger
siblings, so these are all
anecdotal observations that are out there,
but I think it raises the
possibility of all sorts
of really, things that
we haven't thought about
of effects within families
if sometimes cells
from the genetic
individual of our siblings
can be colonizing our
own bodies, thank you.
- Question for Cynthia Beall.
Does the difference between
the Andeans and the Tibetans
reflect the time in
which they have adapted,
or is it the environment
in which they have adapted?
- That's a very good question to which
I don't know the answer.
I would add a third option to
the time and the environment
and that is evolutionary history
and micro-evolutionary history.
It is the case that
someone has been living
on the Tibetan plateau for much longer
than someone has been
living on the Andean plateau
so it's possible that
given another 15,000 years
Andean highlanders might converge
upon the Tibetan phenotype
The fact that we see signals of selection
that are different in the two populations
suggests that that is not going to happen.
The questions about
differences in environment
is an interesting one because
I think what you're doing
is implicitly asking well,
you're focusing on high-altitudes
and you're focusing on
hypoxia, but what about
could dietary differences,
could latitudinal differences
and ultraviolet radiation differences
and infectious disease
differences contribute
to the pattern of differences,
and the answer is yes,
it's possible, we don't have any evidence.
The third option that I introduced is that
the population that gave rise
to the Tibetan population
came from northern eastern
Asia, and that is also
the population that gave
rise to the Native Americans.
And so it's possible that
in the course of moving
from the Old World to the New World,
there was genetic drift,
there were new mutations,
there were adaptations to
other environmental factors
along the way so that the
genome, the details of the genome
that the Andean highlanders
took to altitude
were different than that for Tibetans
and that would be a great
question to sort out.
And if the person who
asked that is looking for
a dissertation topic, go for it.
(applause)
- Okay, so I think Charlie Nunn
takes the prize for the
maximum number of questions.
Sleep, everybody's interested in sleep,
but we can't really go
through all the questions,
but I'll give a sort
of a combined question.
One question which has two flip sides,
one is you highlighted the
risk of short fragmented sleep,
but what about sleeping too much,
either because of sleeping
too much because you're lazy
or because you get some drugs,
could that have an effect
on cognitive deficits
and on the other hand,
do the requirements of modern life
which are very different from
the hunter-gatherer lifestyle
actually require you to have more sleep?
- [Charles] I'm sorry,
say the second one again.
- The second one is given
the stresses and environment
of modern life, could
it be that you actually
need more sleep now that
the hunter-gather needs.
- Yeah, okay.
Well these are really
interesting questions
and clearly there's a lot
that we still don't know
about sleep and it's effects on health.
The evidence that is out suggests
that there's sort of a sweet
spot of around eight hours,
there's probably a lot of error on that
and that sleeping too
little or sleeping too much
will have health consequences,
negative health consequences
and so it probably is the
case that sleeping too much
would also contribute to some
negative health consequences.
Now I don't know a lot about
that side of the equation,
I think most people are
focusing on the other side
in terms of too little sleep.
It's also interesting
to think about whether
the stresses of modern life would lead us
to need more sleep.
I can't say that's really
come up in a lot of our conversations.
The people we study in
Madagascar and I go to Madagascar
with David, I've not yet
been to see the Hadza,
but when we got to Madagascar,
those people are working really hard.
We're of course, often
there in the harvest season
and their activity levels
are incredibly high.
We actually had the hypothesis
that they might sleep
more than eight hours because
they don't have electricity
and I think that there'd
be an argument to say
that they should sleep more
than a typical westerner
does just because of all
the physical activity
that they're undertaking,
hauling firewood,
hauling water, you know,
harvesting these crops,
bringing the crops in,
they're really working hard
so I would actually expect
them to need more sleep
than a typical westerner,
but I think these are
really interesting questions
that we don't yet have answers to them,
so very nice questions, thank you.
(applause)
(pensive piano music)